- Sometimes, incredible
videos on TikTok go well.
Oh, he did it!
And, sometimes,
they go horribly wrong.
(text crashes)
(Mike gasps)
(computer error beeps)
Someone needs to call the doctor.
Huge thanks Audible for
sponsoring this video.
(imitates computer noise)
(upbeat music)
Oh, these, these videos
always freak me out.
Ooh, good catch.
(Mike gasps)
Good catch!
Sick catch.
(cowbell rings)
Ooh, he had like 38 flips!
Backwards catch.
(Mike sharply inhales)
All I'm picturing
(computer error beeps)
is people like that landing
on their necks
(body sound thumps)
and then having, like,
a spinal cord injury.
It's so scary to me.
(woman screams)
(screen whooshes)
Oh, here we go.
(Mike gasps)
(body thumps)
Dude, is there...
Where's the spotter? No spotter?
It's like benching without a spotter.
Probably worse.
(upbeat music)
Ooh, oh! Oh.
I wonder if this person
did that on purpose.
Oh yeah, they did.
(cowbell rings)
They could do tricks and stuff.
I just feel like your toe
would hurt after a while.
Probably don't need
(cowbell rings)
pedicures often.
That's so cool.
Oh!
(body slaps)
And that is how you get a neck injury.
(TikToker laughs)
Oh, that's funny.
Growing up in Brooklyn,
you lived on those.
You collected nickels until you saved
up 99 cents to purchase those.
And what you do is you throw them
on the floor and they make a
(Bang snap pops)
popping sound.
Parents hated them. My
grandparents hated them.
(camera whooshes)
So much fun.
(Bang snaps pop)
(man screams)
(Mike laughs)
He screamed 'cause he
probably burned himself.
- What is your deal?
Torture.
(fire roars)
This flip is wild. Oh no.
Oh no. Oh no.
Oh no.
Oh!
(synth rings)
Oh my God.
If he would've got, if he
would've got back on the bike,
I would say he deserves an award.
I would go on his Patreon and sub.
You should go
(sound effect chirps)
on my Patreon and sub, by the way.
We have a Patreon community
where all the money gets donated
to charity, but you get access
to an exclusive Discord.
Thought it was a good way to plug it.
(upbeat music)
Wow. But wow.
He caught the bike.
Oh, he did it! He did it!
Oh, he caught the bike and flipped it.
I don't know much about this sport,
but that's gotta be like,
top five trick of all time.
The Scouts all over me.
(baseball bat rings)
(Mike gasps)
Oh!
(rubbing sound rings)
You know, what's funny?
That's probably not gonna cause
him any real injury outside
of just like, immense pain
for a short period of time.
(baseball bat rings)
(keyboard clack)
(screen whooshes)
Okay.
(record scratches)
I already know this is gonna end poorly,
simply because this branch
(sound effect boings)
just looks flimsy.
(branch crackles)
(body smacks)
Oh! See? How could she
have not predicted that?
I think she was okay with that.
(screen whooshes)
Oh man. What is this?
Again, doing it for the 'gram.
He's benching a bench.
(metal sound crashes)
Is he, did he weigh the bench first...
I have so many questions.
The chain around his neck is
supposed to work his abs more.
But my question with that is,
do you really want pressure
(water sound boings)
around your carotid artery
while you're exercising?
My answer is probably not.
- [Tiktoker] Yes.
- Oh!
(skateboard wheels hum)
He's going down. Oh?
He, he...
(Mike gasps)
(skateboard clacks)
Oh!
Oh, oh.
How did he not tear
his ACL, MCL, LCL, PCL?
So many injuries.
(body sound slaps)
(screen whooshes)
(mysterious music)
By far the dumbest thing
I've tried in the gym.
Oh, I didn't even realize
what was happening.
It, it took me a second.
Now, see, I would find this cool.
If instead of having weights on one side,
and the dude on the other side,
he had twins, identical twins hanging.
(screen whooshes)
Ooh, ooh.
Ooh!
(body thumps)
Clavicle fracture, shoulder dislocation.
Easy on that.
Wow. Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Honestly, definitely just
keeping going because
of the video.
If there was no video,
staying down.
(cowbell rings)
These are so dangerous,
like, never do this.
Not on the road.
Just don't.
(text smacks)
(crowd chatters)
(Mike gasps)
(computer error beeps)
Oh, god.
How do you let your friend do that?
That was so obvious that
that was gonna happen.
(ball smacks)
And you know what I'm
even more upset about?
That he kicked a football
with his bare foot.
You know how easy it is
to break a toe
(bones crack) like that?
Think about the toe.
(cowbell rings)
(screen whooshes)
This man in his 70s flipped off the swing.
Well, yeah, he's probably
having some words said...
Whoa!
(cowbell rings)
I thought he was gonna flip
off the swing negatively.
Wow, my man just picked
(glass sound clinks)
up his groceries and said,
"Let's go to Whole Foods, baby."
(TV static crackles)
- Back to the TikToks in just a second.
But first, I wanna thank Audible
for sponsoring this video.
Last week, I interviewed
Professor Roy Baumeister
about his book, Willpower:
(computer sound rings)
Rediscovering the Greatest Human Strength.
I found this book on Audible
and I was so into it.
I just had to have Professor Baumeister
on the channel to dive in deeper.
We discuss tips on how
to improve willpower, how
to battle decision fatigue.
Even the debate surrounding
the famous marshmallow experiment.
Make sure to go watch that
interview after this video
and sign up for Audible today,
by going to audible.com/doctormike.
Or, text "DOCTOR MIKE"
to the number 500-500.
Remember though, doctor is spelled out,
and that will begin
your free 30 day trial.
With that, you'll have access
to Audible's premium selection
and Audible plus catalogue,
giving you access
to the latest best sellers,
guided meditations podcasts,
and so much more.
The link to sign up is down below
and the end card after this
video will take you straight
to my interview with Professor Baumeister.
All right, let's get back to these TikToks
and see what happens.
(lips smack)
(upbeat music)
Oh my God, this is terrible.
Why would you do this?
I...
Hip dislocation is happening.
This is not
(computer error beeps)
normal human anatomy physiology.
So like, the only thing that is normal
in this image to me is the
dude holding the cell phone,
leaning over, trying to
stay out of the shot,
but failing to do so.
Everything else about this,
it's not that it's not normal.
It's extreme amazingness
and a lot of leopard print.
(screen whooshes)
- [TikTok Sound] Turning off gravity.
You are now free to float.
(intense music)
- Whoa! Those are some
powerful pecks and scaps.
Wow.
Rhomboids,
everything activated.
(dramatic music)
(screen whooshes)
(upbeat music)
Making my way downtown.
Oh no. Is there a person
(water sound boings)
on the stretcher?
Is there someone on that gurney?
No way. No way.
No, no. There's no one on it.
There is?
Oh, you better sprint after that person.
They're in the crosswalk.
Oh, that's malpractice.
(cowbell rings)
(faint music)
Now this is fun.
This is like one of those game shows.
Ooh, ooh.
Ooh, it speeds up.
Ooh, ooh!
Ooh, ooh.
(TikToker laughs)
(TikToker screams)
Ah! Dodge!
Dip! Duck! It's like one
(computer error beeps)
of those bull riding
things where you're like,
you get on, like, "This is cake" and then,
two seconds later,
(body smacks)
you're flying across the room.
(screen whooshes)
Oh no, I feel like the ball's
gonna come at the screen.
Is that what's gonna happen?
(ball clacks)
(Mike gasps)
(crowd gasps)
How did he just eat it? He ate it!
(body sound smacks) Did he have
some kind of eye protection?
- [Cameraman] I think it hit his forehead,
so it hit the helmet.
- Oh, wow. Balls.
- [Cameraman] (indistinct) Do
you not duck outta the way?
(computer error beeps)
- Balls on multiple levels.
(text crashes)
(screen whooshes)
(footsteps patter)
Whoa,
(synth rings)
that was a lot higher
than I thought it was.
If you don't land that fall
with feet first accuracy
(siren whistles)
and you belly flop,
that's a dangerous fall.
(water sound boings)
I don't recommend that.
(upbeat music)
Okay.
Oh, oh. It's a transformer.
It's a transformer robot. Why
does he have (cowbell rings)
a helicopter thing?
That's kind of cool, though.
Oh my God, I kind of wanna do that.
How do I get one of those?
(cowbell rings)
Kisses a guy with facial hair
thinking it was a good idea at the time.
Anaphylactic reaction?
- [Cameraman] I think it's beard burn.
- Oh, beard burn.
Actually, you know what
that looks like to me?
Staph auereus.
(bell rings)
Wow, that looks painful.
That look, must have been
some aggressive kissing.
(screen whooshes)
(TikToker sniffs)
Oh, those are ants?
(cowbell rings)
I thought they were seeds, too.
Oh my God.
I mean, it's not bad.
You just got some extra protein.
But I just wouldn't continue.
(computer error beeps)
'Cause you don't know
where those ants have been.
(crowd chatters)
Oh, ganglion cyst.
(keyboard clack)
(crowd chatters)
(TikToker groans in foreign language)
This is not the way
(computer error beeps)
you drain a ganglion cyst.
The way we do it is one of two options.
One, stick a needle in it, drain it out.
Or two,
(water sound boings)
actually remove the entire cyst itself,
because that works better in terms
of having less chance that it recurs.
Doing it this way, you can cause trauma
to the surrounding area,
including the bone,
ligaments, et cetera.
Also, good to point out, that
you don't have to drain them.
They're not bothering you and
they're just there, it's fine.
(screen whooshes)
- Yeah, I thought I was
an ENFP but then I took it
and they made up a new combo for me.
- [TikToker's Cameraman]
What's the new combo?
- It's just all of them,
(Mike chuckles) every letter.
Nope, the Hogwarts house
quiz isn't accurate.
I took it and they just
said I was never accepted.
Do you know what your love language is?
- I think I've taken
(water effect boings)
all of these.
- And then I receive
love just through cash.
(Mike laughs)
- Through cash!
- Yeah, I would, I got my physical,
and they did a "What
blood work are you?" quiz
and, and I'm anemic.
(camera whooshes)
- "What blood work are you?" quiz?
That's how I'm gonna pitch it
to my patients from now on.
Check out my interview
with Professor Roy Baumeister here.
Talks all about willpower,
decision fatigue,
basically, how to get you motivated
to take on anything
you wish to accomplish.
Huge thanks to Audible
for sponsoring this video.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)